in 2013 the left went nuts over a rodeo
clown the rodeo clown was performing at
the Missouri State Fair he had the awful
temerity to wear a mask of then
President Obama we're going to stump
Obama now announcer said hey I know I'm
a clown the rodeo clown replied he's
just running around acting like one
doesn't know he is one the media quoted
a bystander who compared the act to a
KKK rally lieutenant governor of the
state condemned the act as did one of
the Senators the rodeo clown was fired
even though he dressed up as other
presidents in the past and on the exact
same routine fast forward four years on
Tuesday TMZ posted photos of comedian
Kathy Griffin was helped host CNN's New
Year's Eve coverage for a decade holding
a mock-up of President severed head
covered in blood Griffin has a long
record of anti-trump sentiment of course
in February she told MSNBC's Chris
Matthews quote I'm big resister and I
don't believe in compromise with this
president I also think he's crazy
I think he's mentally ill he's also an
idiot but this photo should cross a
rather obvious line it celebrated
Trump's perspective murder
imagine if anyone on the right had done
something similar with Obama the outcry
would have been deafening yet the same
people who asked for trigger warnings
for material that might offend anyone
the same people who believe there's a
rape culture that pervades America the
same people who say president Trump has
incentivized the culture of political
violence across the land many of them
are silent about Griffin's antics why
because political violence is no longer
taboo in the u.s. it's just another
tactic to utilize when useful and when
useful and denigrate when others engaged
in it that sentiment expresses itself on
both sides of the political aisle when
Montana House candidate Greg Ginn Forte
allegedly body-slammed a reporter
prominent conservatives including talk
show host Laura Ingraham meaning his
victim is was and champion Gian Forte is
a sort of stalwart man's man when
leftist attacked Trump rallies during
the 2016 election cycle the media
attempted to paint them as the defenders
of the common good against Trump himself
the overuse for a cycle of violence is
often used by the press to refer to
situations in which an aggressor acts
violently and somebody defends them but
we've entered an actual cycle in
political violent rhetoric whereby the
violence of the left provokes a direct
response from the right and vice versa
and it's getting worse if you spend all
day proclaiming that you're in a civil
war with other Americans that you're
part of a resistance it's only a matter
of time until you become willing to look
the other way at violence itself if
Americans aren't your brothers and
sisters if we disagree then they will
quickly become your enemies Kathy
Griffin may think it's hilarious
to hold up a bloody head of the
President of the United States but she's
tearing away at the social fabric far
more than president Trump is and those
who backs her play are helping provoke
their enemies to respond in kind I'm Ben
Shapiro this is dementia Pierrot show
so Donald Trump today very very very
good thing and we are very happy about
that today so we'll be discussing all
aspects of the Paris Accord what Trump
did what he said
he gave what I thought was the best
speech of his presidency thus far really
really good speech that gave about the
Paris Accords yesterday before we get to
that though I want to say thank you to
our sponsors over at upside comm so this
is the best new way to travel if you are
interested in traveling for cheap if you
are interested in receiving back the
hundreds of dollars in gift cards from
amazon.com with every purchase you go to
upside comm and use a radio listener
promo bend here's the way they do it
they bundle your flight in your hotel
together and because they are
specifically designed for business
travelers so they're really designed for
person traveling alone they get the
cheapest prices available bundling saves
money especially on business travel so
up side actually gives you back free
Amazon gift cards if your frequent
business traveler your company saves a
bunch of money on the price and you
personally get thousands a year just for
buying your air and hotel together at
upside calm and you still get all your
miles it's foolish not to check it out
upside calm if you're shopping for
business or personal travel it takes
three minutes to see how much you can
save by buying your flights and hotel
together for one low price and right now
if you use the code Bend if you use my
name Ben you're guaranteed to get at
least a $200 Amazon gift card on your
very first trip my name Ben gets you a
$200 Amazon gift card on your very first
trip again you say big and you get the
big gift card kickback to you every
single trip upside calm terrific service
minimum purchases required to decide for
complete details and remember use that
promo code Ben so you get the $200 in
gift cards pretty hefty gift right there
get $200 in gift cards with minimum
purchase and also that lets them know
that we sent you so they continue to a
sponsor the program we continue to bring
it to you okay so president Trump in my
absence I leave for two days and many a
thing has happened but the big thing
that happened is a very good thing and
that is President Trump came out and he
rejected the Paris Accord so for people
who don't know what the Paris Accord is
I think that it's important to spell
what this is out so people understand
first of all it was basically it
basically the Accord was President Obama
in the very last days of his
administration he went to Paris and he
met with all of these nations
and they all agreed to voluntarily
submit these non-binding resolutions on
how they were going to cut their carbon
emissions that's basically what it was
now there are a couple problems here
number one non-binding number two none
of the resolutions was rejected and
there was nobody there who said well you
know Congo you did a terrible job here
this is you know that whatever country
it is France
you're not recommending that you cut
enough China you're not recommending you
cut enough so we reject your resolution
we want you to bring a new resolution to
the table and here's an enforcement
mechanism basically it was like you and
a group of your friends pledged that
you're going to lose weight and you get
to pick your own targets so you have a
friend who comes in and says I want to
lose one pound over the next six months
everybody a and a friend really needs to
lose 50 pounds not a useful thing also
no enforcement mechanism so if they
don't lose the 1 pound nobody says to
them that was kind of bad you said
you're going to lose a pound and you
didn't so it was basically just a bunch
of people slapping each other on the
back pretending they were doing
something for the world when actually
they weren't doing anything for the
world
Trump pulls out of the Accord because
what he says is it's just a way for
people to generate anti-us headlines in
other words we bomb acum it'ld to a
bunch of resolutions about lowering
lowering our carbon emissions that we
were never going to be knowing that his
successor would then have to eat it
right that we didn't meet those
resolutions then his successor the
United States would then be labeled as
backing off its commitments being ripped
up and down he was making a promise that
somebody else's body was going to have
to cash and because of that Trump says
look this whole agreement is a joke and
we're pulling out so Trump speaks
yesterday and he gives a very good
speech this is why he was elected you
know it was for stuff like this here he
was explaining what exactly it would do
to the United States to abide by the
actual resolutions that we had adopted
with regard to the Paris Accord
compliance with the terms of the Paris
Accord and the owners energy
restrictions at his place in the United
States could cost America as much as 2.7
million lost jobs by 2025
according to the National Economic
Research Associates this includes four
hundred and forty thousand fewer
manufacturing jobs not what we need
believe me this is not
what we need including automobile jobs
and the further decimation of vital
American industries on which countless
communities rely they rely for so much
and we would be giving them so little
according to the same study by 2040
compliance with the commitments put into
place by the previous administration
would cut production for the following
sectors paper down 12% cement down 23%
iron and steel down 38% coal and I
happen to love the coal miners down 86%
natural gas down 31% ok so the reason
that this is good what he's doing right
here is he's spelling out a trade-off
that Obama refused to acknowledge
actually occurs and that trade-off is if
you place heavy regulations on American
industries jobs are lost if you place
heavy regulations on American carbon
emissions then there's going to be an
economic cost to that and people on the
right and the left pretend that this is
not the case Trump you'll see later
actually pretends the opposite is the
case he says well we can have all the
environmental as we want and we can also
have as much economic growth as we want
ie not super true but his balance is
closer to the correct balance that
Obama's balance was close to the correct
balance so he spells out the cost to
Americans and he's not going to lose a
single vote in 2018 or 2020 based on
this there are a lot of people who feel
like these regulations and I've spoken
in Pennsylvania recently you talk to
manufacturers in Pennsylvania they are
afraid the regulations are going to
destroy their industry and they are
right he continues along these lines and
he points out that there would be a lot
of loss in the economy if you continue
along the lines of these Paris Accords
the cost of the economy at this time
would be close to three trillion dollars
in lost GDP and six and a half million
industrial jobs
while households would have $7,000 less
income and in many cases much worse than
that
okay and this is again true what he's
saying is that basically the cost of
energy production go up dramatically
when you put heavy regulations on energy
production and that means that people
are going to have less money to spend on
other things again true he continues
along these lines and this is where when
Trump said America first there were
people who were saying okay if you were
talking about this kind of stuff that
I'm with him okay when he says America
first what he what he should be meaning
is that we can't allow other countries
to go on doing exactly what they want
with their industries and then
unilaterally cut our own economy to no
net effect he picks on China here and
he's right to pick on China China is not
going to make any serious emissions cuts
all of the emissions cuts that China has
talked about under the Paris Accord are
things they are already doing there are
things that are already occurring so for
example in the United States in the last
couple of years we've cut our carbon
emissions by three percent that's not
because of regulations
that's because natural gas has replaced
in many cases coal production and
natural gas gives off less emissions
than coal production it's because our
cars are getting more efficient in other
words free markets make more green
energy than two government mandates
government mandates just make people
poor but China is going to be able to do
what they want and we're supposed to
regulate ourselves to no effect here is
from saying that for example under the
agreement China will be able to increase
these emissions by a staggering number
of years 13 they can do whatever they
want for 13 years not us India makes its
participation contingent on receiving
billions and billions and billions of
dollars in foreign aid from developed
countries there are many other examples
but the bottom line is that the Paris
Accord is very unfair at the highest
level to the United States I don't think
that a lot of Americans who are going to
disagree with that and he is correct
that the reason the rest of the world is
so intent on the United States picking
up the burden is because they would like
to see the United States taken down a
peg on the global economic level he
points that out and again the
exactly correct from President Trump the
rest of the world applauded when we
signed the Paris agreement they went
wild they were so happy for the simple
reason that it put our country the
United States of America which we all
love at a very very big economic
disadvantage a cynic would say the
obvious reason for economic competitors
and they wish to see us remain in the
agreement is so that we continue to
suffer this self-inflicted major
economic wound in fact ever then that's
exactly right finally that the final
point that he makes it's really an
important one is that even if we were to
comply by all of the resolutions that
have been undertaken in the Paris Accord
again non-binding resolutions undertaken
in the Paris Accord it wouldn't really
make much of a difference over the
course of the century so here he is
explaining using data from MIT that if
people just did what they were talking
about under the Paris Accord it wouldn't
actually do anything but would hurt the
economy pretty badly even if the Paris
agreement were implemented in full with
total compliance from all nations it is
estimated it would only produce a
two-tenths of one degree think of that
this much Celsius reduction in global
temperature by the year 2100
tiny tiny amount in fact 14 days of
carbon emissions from China alone would
wipe out the gains from America and this
is incredible statistic would totally
wipe out the gains from America's
expected reductions in the year 2030
after we have had to spend billions and
billions of dollars lost jobs closed
factories and suffered at they right and
this is Trump doing the right thing he
drops a line in here that I think really
sums up what his
residency should be about what it what
he's always said it was about he said I
was elected to represent the citizens of
Pittsburgh not Paris and that is totally
fair that is a smart political line now
the left has absolutely lost its mind
over this and I want to talk in one
second about that but first I want to
talk about all of the reasons why what
Trump did was right
but before I even get to that first I
want to say thank you to our sponsors
over in doe Chino so the nicest suit
that I currently own is a suit from
indigene oh it's a tailored suit it's
it's kind of a blue gray suit really
beautiful suit and it's tailored to me
the way that it works you go over to
Indo Chino comm and they ask for all
sorts of measurements and you can
measure it yourself can go over to one
of their stores Indochina has one in
Beverly Hills that I went to and they
suit you up I mean they you pick your
fabric you pick the weave you pick the
the lining you pick all the various
options you want cuffs on your on your
pants you now on cuffs do you want
pleats and it basically all the options
and it's customized just for you people
men look better in tailored suits just
the fact there's a reason bond only
wears tailored suits in de Chino makes
that happen for you right now if you go
to Indo Chino and you ing och Ino com
use promo code Shapiro you get any
premium enjoy Chino suit for just 379
bucks so that's like an off-the-rack
price suit but it's actually tailored to
you it's tailored to you so it fits you
absolutely perfectly and by the way if
they tailor it wrong you just bring it
back in and they will fix it for you at
their shop or you can send it back to
them for fixes so Indo Chino calm right
now my listeners get any of those in
premium in Ticino suits for just 379
bucks at Indo Chino calm when you enter
Shapiro at checkout that also lets them
know that we sent you which is which is
great for us 50% off the regular price
for made-to-measure premium suits and
again shipping is free
it fits you better than anything you're
gonna get off the rack ever would
because it is made just for you I mean
they do things that are really
sophisticated with the suit like when
they were fitting it to me they actually
said okay we remove the shoulders
forward we're going to release the we're
going to release the buy so because
you're just so massive in the bicep and
it was and it was the super glue looks
good I mean it's a sense to me in a in a
beautiful box I take it out if it's
perfectly it's great enzo Chino calm
promo code Shapiro okay so a few more
notes about the Paris Accord then I only
got some left's insane reaction to this
because it's totally over the top so
number one the Accord was actually a
tree
but Obama never treated it that way so
if Obama really thought this was super
duper too very important super-dee-duper
important then what he should have done
is signed the Paris Accords with some
pretty significant American restrictions
on carbon emissions and then submitted
it to the Senate and use his bully
pulpit to get it approved remember
treaties under the US Constitution must
be approved by two-thirds of the Senate
so if he thinks it's that important if
the world is at stake if we're all going
to dive it's going to be the day after
tomorrow and Dennis Quaid is going to be
hiding in the subway station while the
waves pour through New York City then
you would think you might be able to get
two-thirds of senators to vote for this
thing Obama couldn't even do that when
he had 60 senators from the Democratic
Party there so the idea that this is
ever going to be a political winner for
Democrats is really stupid also if
you're going to do a treaty do a treaty
a second there are some significant
legal and implementation problems with
the Paris Accord so Donald McGann is the
White House Counsel he pointed out that
theoretically you could have a court
that would strike down the EPA's
proposals to kill some of these anti
coal regulations on the basis of the
Paris Accords now legally should they be
able to do that no the left says the
courts wouldn't do that
of course the left's also said 15 20
years ago that the courts wouldn't
impose gay marriage from above and then
they did that so whenever the left says
the courts will not do this what they
really mean is the courts won't do this
tomorrow but in the next six months
maybe third this would have had no
impact like none okay the the statistic
the Trump cites there where he says the
global climate would be lowered by a
grand total of 0.2 degrees celsius by
2100 if we kept by the Paris Accord that
is 100% true mit is saying no no no no
that that's that's only if people stop
dividing by their obligations in 2030
Rabbid the Paris Accord only runs
through 2030 so what is he supposed to
assume that we're going to Ratchet it up
after 2030 chemica sumption is about
facts not in evidence for that lets
other countries freeride Oren cast out a
commentary magazine today China
committed to begin reducing emissions by
2030 roughly 1 at economic development
would have caused this to happen anyway
India made no emissions commitment
pledging only to make progress on
efficiency at half the rate it had
progressed in recent years
Pakistan out did the rest submitting a
single page that offered to quote reduce
its emissions after reaching peak levels
to the extent possible this is a
definition of the word peak not a
commitment in April report by Transport
Environment found only three European
countries pursuing policies in line with
their parents can
and one of these Germany has now seen
two straight years of emissions
increases the Philippines has outright
renounced its commitment a study
published by the American Geophysical
Union warns that India's planned coal
plant construction is incompatible with
its own target and all of this is fine
the only people who get ripped through
the United States because of course
we're the most powerful we're also
supposed to fund like one-third of the
entire commitment for all of the for all
of the Paris Accord redistribution is
put like three billion dollars and Obama
and the left have been claiming for
years that this is going to create jobs
no evidence it's going to create jobs
Paris Accord was basically meaningless
now that said it is important to point
out that you know the the Trump pulling
out of it doesn't actually materially
change much because the Paris Accords
weren't going to be implemented in any
case they're going to have the same
shelf life as the Kyoto Protocol adopted
by the Clinton administration in 1997
never passed by it never ratified by the
Senate and basically DOA
so it's a big symbolic move but
symbolism matters when it comes to this
stuff and that's it's the symbolism the
left is going nuts over so the left has
completely lost its mind and it's really
funny stuff so we're going to discuss
all that but for that I'm going to have
to go over to Daley wired.com right now
and become a subscriber for $8 a month
you can subscribe at Daley wire.com you
can part of the mailbag which we are
doing today and it will be spectacular
we'll take live questions you can get
all of your life's questions answered
you can see Andrew Clavin show live you
can be part of clave ins mailbag as well
we have lots of other goodies coming in
right now if you become an annual
subscriber even if you're a regular
subscriber if you buy an annual
subscription now if you upgrade and
become an annual subscriber you get a
free signed copy a brand new book by me
and my dad called say it so Papa dad me
and a 2005 White Sox Champion season
it's all about the it's all about
fathers and sons in baseball I think
it's a really fun interesting and kind
of heartwarming book it's great for
Father's Day perfect Father's Day gift
go to inferencing right now so if you've
already ordered wait a few days we're in
the process of getting all of those
signs it's for you I will sign it for
you get free autographed copy when you
come the annual subscribers to go over
to daily wire comm right now and check
it out we appreciate it if you just want
to listen later go to iTunes or
SoundCloud become a subscriber and then
make sure that you leave us a review
over in iTunes because we know that we
we know that apparently it affects
iTunes rankings for some odd reason but
in any case make sure that you subscribe
we appreciate your listenership
we are the largest conservative podcast
in the nation
[Music]
you